no a white straight male needs
nak 15 okay and I'll say what about
before me would know okay that's know
where they no they didn't mean any they
are forty sevens do the research that's
absolutely correct
we'll have it listed yes I agree with
you Chang so getting much that's
absolutely right
when you use the F word you know it's
real okay so we have a bunch of people
who wanted to make phone calls to the
show because we have a discussion so
let's have the first caller
high genic Paul Joseph Watson here first
time caller I'd really like to get your
clarification on the Armenian Genocide
specifically if you accept the
historical hi-hi Chang I'm not sure if
you remember me I was on your show a
while back and and you you asked me
demanded that I make you a ham sandwich
that was just kind of wondering if you
still wanted that sandwich I could
probably put it in the mail for you
everybody knows as if it is a joke okay
the phone you anti-woman poor
sandwich-making [ __ ] if you won't have
a reasonable guy okay but no come on
talk about a ham sandwich and i guess
that answers my question
so no right
hey [ __ ] as someone you've previously
misquoted in borderline slandered on
your show I'm wondering if you can speak
to the research in fact checking behind
your show
okay listen I understand this is what he
wants to do with this oh okay
phone you YouTube beta male discussion
right discussion talk about issues not
talk about this [ __ ] so he knows I'm
I'm in I'm in deep I know predictable
alright let's go to next caller hi this
is Ben Shapiro and I was just wondering
your production values are fabulous and
I was wondering where you got your money
was it was it from Soros or was it from
anti-freedom nations in the Middle East
like Qatar look it right
Shapiro's thing is all the time to think
you're bothered you're low on energy
okay let's get time for a bacon grease
break I don't need bacon grease okay
come on come on get your bacon grease no
I don't get your bacon grease yeah
got that fat hey sink
Dean Cain here I haven't called before
I've heard about you show us stuff so I
asked you a question
get off the phone you Clark Kent
Superman 90s sitcom pretty boy [ __ ] what
call me okay all right I mean it's not
just me you know like okay one more he
can't game Rubin here former employee uh
so I noticed that you talk about sam
Harris a lot you really obsess over the
guy so my question to you is are you
sexually attracted to Sam Harris very
funny right we all get it Dave Rubin
used to be a part of the Young Turks oh
yeah he's going to listen I like the guy
okay I like Reuben he loves the show
okay get off the phone you homophobic
Joker looking you don't have to
subscribe to this channel
okay look if you want to have reasonable
discussions you should subscribe if you
want to learn something and use fats and
that just be racist and homophobic by
the way that man is genocide like right
never happen okay
subscribe